once upon a time
HTC was a thriving phone maker with lots
of popular phones released last year the
HTC One garnered awards and rave reviews
but then things took a turn for the
worse nobody bought it the villains were
likely HTC's own supply issues and an
aggressive marketing campaigns from
Samsung and Apple now if this were a
real fairy tale the new HTC One m8 would
become the king of the Android kingdom
after all the m8 has a brand new design
and even more powerful camera and it's
gonna be available at all US carriers
this week for 199 dollars but if people
turn their back on the first best
Android phone ever will they embrace a
new one wrapped in a solid piece of
smooth metal with rounded edges this is
one nice phone to hold though I wish the
company had stuck with the 4.7 inch
screen the bigger 5-inch 1080p screen is
beautiful it's just harder to navigate
with one hand
HTC did remove the physical buttons on
the phone and integrated them right on
the screen to save space but still it's
longer than most phones and that's
because of the boom sound speakers yeah
the name is unfortunate but the speakers
actually do produce a pretty loud sound
there are also some really cool camera
upgrades you'll notice here on the back
that there are two cameras this is the
main camera but this one up here
actually collects focus information or
depth information so you can tap on a
photo and then refocus it it works
surprisingly well and then there are
loads of other fun photo tricks too
I didn't say they were useful the photos
themselves captured by the ultra pixel
camera are decent though not as crisp as
the ones I've taken with the iPhone 5s
that said the simple camera interface is
better than any I've seen on a phone an
Ellen DeGeneres is going to love this
there's a selfie mode which snaps photos
to the improve front-facing camera and
there's a tool to make your face look
thinner not that any of us need that HTC
has made some improvements to its blink
widget which brings in news and social
media feeds but I didn't use it much I
did use the double tap to wake feature a
lot though and if you buy this awesome
$50 case you can see the time and the
weather right through it it totally
looks like a light break not everything
is perfect though when you make
selections on the screen it makes these
electric shock sounds I could not
disable that fast enough the battery
life also could be better and the
keyboard is hard to type on in the end
the HTC One m8 may not break a lot of
new ground but it's still one of the
greatest Android phones ever made no it
isn't water-resistant and it doesn't
have a heart rate monitor like Samsung's
Galaxy s5 but the software and the
hardware design are better unless your
Samsung or Apple the smartphone business
these days is in a fairytale in a
perfect story more people would ignore
the ads listen to me and live happily
ever after
with this phone